hey sport we know you're still sleeping
but we know that we'll all be reunited
in the colony that you built
[Music]
no one told us what happened to the ship
what happened it knocked it off course
where's the captain
everybody that was in charge of running
this ship is dead
[Music]
it all falls to us now
we have some of the most brilliant
engineers and scientists
chosen to build a colony from scratch on
an alien planet
the furthest out anyone's ever been who
could attack us
I've got bad news
life support warning
and do this
our journey ends here because to be
honest I really thought traveling faster
than the speed of light was going to be
a little more fun let's Crank It Up
single person matters
rid of War for survival
not everyone is going to make it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
this is grief counseling anyone's
invited to speak
people meet me and they think she's the
woman whose nephew
survived the plane crash
but they forget I'm also cool who lost
my big sister
[Music]
what are you doing drinking champagne by
myself out of a Juice Glass
lost my husband I lost my best friend
but he had another life so I don't know
how to piece it all together
after I got to 200 I lost count
why does everyone writing to him
because he survived
I know you want to run away I want to
run away too but life has to go on
I don't know who I am join the club
[Music]
I'm sure you've heard great things oh no
no secrets in grief group
that my grandmother paved the way and
there is no one more committed to
carrying on her Legacy than I am
foreign
[Music]
but I'm going to do my best to take care
of you
[Music]
and that is the truth that will never go
away
[Music]
look at what the cat a choked on and
regurgitated I made it myself
I know who to blame
for the year that we've all had what is
everyone getting into next why don't you
have like hellerons to make right I
guess I didn't make a great first
impression on you none of the
Impressions you made on me
but am I Flirting With Disaster
drama returns look at me so clean no
effort I found someone that I feel great
about how many orgasms I should give you
I lost count after eight do not get
sweater yourself now these are adorable
that's not where those
goal I just booked the coast I wrote
that Christmas
hi I loved you in Moesha excuse me sorry
confession time I've never seen Moesha
my husband said it was hashtag canceled
because it gives a woman too many ideas
and I get that
oh you need a boss chick look at
this I'm the one that says trashy
tie she's the waitress during our date
at the table they can't just keep
printing lies like this lies right oh
look at the Black Twist
so you're gonna be a hater all your life
if I choose to you are something
beautiful I wish I was a stupid
baby girl
it does
[Music]
I see you on my lips
you have been through a lot in nine
years
and I'm very proud of you
it's not over yet
I need your help to save the world
I have nothing to live for yes you do
I'll show you
John buried
people
clutch let's do this one last time the
flash final season begins February 8th
free next day only on the CW app
Professor Jonathan Moore
why are you here
[Music]
come on
oh did someone break your heart
did you break my heart Marion
I walked along the Avenue
heartbreak is always a catalyst for A
New Path You're a murderer Joe you're
wrong about me I'm gonna prove it to you
laying low is imperative
turns out teaching's fun and London's
not so bad
I fell in with the most insane damaged
people on earth a circle of privileged
douchebags but I do miss having someone
out there hello no
no I am not interested nope not
interested
I don't want to know oh
where did you go why does the universe
keep doing this to me police are
continuing to investigate a second
murder among the elite they're calling
him to eat the rich killer
[Music]
you think one of my friends is the
Killer
stop playing shitty Sherlock
all motives always boil down to sex
money or Revenge
foreign
[Music]
if he was hiding in plain sight
are you
you steal my Spotlight and I murder you
I just want my little European holiday
back
I couldn't get away
we are all just our ancestors dreams
and our success represents
those dreams coming dreams coming true
take over
[Applause]
what is standard bearers of hip-hop
perform atomically be on top of the game
right now
that's the limit son let me take a
moment and appreciate
it's like in hip-hop everyone is looking
for the next thing
my point is is that we have to do
everything to hold our position while we
got it
I always envisioned a better life but
y'all taking it really far we're
two-thirds through the recording budget
we started on the show for it at some
point it all comes down to delivery what
if is going up in my face
needs heat right away or you're dead in
the water I'm looking for a new style
and tongue always needs to be moving
forward stop trying to control
everything it's only a matter of time
before they start to present you for why
are you changing our brand y'all can't
just trust me yo how about you trust us
I can see it
is way more fun when it's out of
control son
OS money from us that they owe
they gonna sue us for money we don't
have we got work to do
killer be careful what you want us to do
go to war we gotta win
all the time
Wu-Tang versus the world
he doesn't see
[Music]
security
numbers
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thought maybe you could help
he was stationed on a supply train that
got robbed last night
only one type of crutch I know that
could fly him up there
you think a pigs did this who else
I'm not police not anymore I can't help
you
we are a nation under attack from within
it is my duty to send a message to any
church considering sedition
a gift from the chancellor to the Fine
people of the row
executed without even a child innocent
men
while it's falling apart and we can't
just sit at home and do nothing what
have you got in mind
[Music]
take a closer look at what you're doing
to us
I thought if we were peaceful they'd
show us Mercy
but now we know the truth if they shoot
at US Nail our heads against a wall they
will pay for it in their own blood
you go after them they'll come for all
of us the whole row will burn
[Music]
they should be afraid of us
foreign
[Music]
you want to marry V
and have this baby
I want the life I was so close to having
I could taste them
until they ripped it away
you were supposed to be out out
I built an Empire
starting back in zero
that ain't gonna happen
you know exactly who we dealing with
if you don't give back what you stole
it's gonna get real bad for you
swallow your pride and make peace with
your family
this isn't good for anyone
told you the gloves had to come off
Franklin is going to war
he's trying to bring this entire
operation crashing down
what exactly do you need proof the CIA
has been selling cocaine in the United
States
tell me even after all of this
you want to think America still cares
about you
it never occur to you this is exactly
what they want
for us to wipe each other out
what happens in excellent times the
course of the rest of our lives
the dream with plans
this is about survival
do it
in this right now
[Music]
dreaming of a place
my Pop's always said nothing good comes
easy
nothing worthy it's good
question is
what are you willing to do
to win
how far
will you go
treasure
[Applause]
[Music]
Paradise
and our new world my whole life was
based online can't go back to the way
things were a real man doesn't avoid
hard things
he faces but scarcity
get dressed and buckle up fool yeah
take off the cloud Chase take off the
Wi-Fi we need to talk the house just
isn't the same when Will's not home it's
a real world outside what's going on
will I just want to take care of myself
got me sing the songs I made where'd
this money come from there's a couple
street ball games no big deal you
stepping away
okay now I'm worried
I did what I did for Will's sake what's
Philly weather's back baby but he's
Reviving back to his old ways let's go
there's this big time Scout and he
talked a lot of dudes get to the pose
that fancy Bel Air Team got you and your
game so if you can't work with me sky's
the limit because if I know we need to
talk about our partnership you're a boss
I'm just trying to bring it out if you
don't accept the tone she's gonna keep
on walking all over you
I was trying to be someone different for
the BSU the protests all people see are
my mistakes yeah forever let anyone try
to change you
that can't believe you're going back so
soon well baby you know I can't sit
still for too long when is it my time to
feel valued
I wish to create a legacy where we are
represented
I think it's time you take the gloves
off babe right Carlton
yeah I'm on the wrong team
I want to be friends anymore
I have anxiety trying to fit into this
goddamn Bellow bubble we all need to
step up you gotta need Jeffrey Wisdom
foreign
[Music]
hello
can I help you
your attention please
my name is Regis patoff
I offer very simple service
[Music]
if it helps you to see me as a monster
so be it
we work for sociopaths
I'm looking forward to getting to know
you all personally hello hello hello
[Music]
thank you for being an important part in
our success
you're valued
at all
[Music]
hello party down catering
yes of course we're open for business
I just need your event info and I will
help you get the party started
[Music]
this is an important event no personal
business on company ah group photo okay
get the whole gang weren't we the gang
and you were more management now it's a
party down reunion and just what
everyone's dying for
this is a big opportunity you want Time
Professional Service
this is not how I envisioned my 40s
are you okay you know I had some silver
for gravitas
oh
remember what we're not gonna rock your
body the boat Henry the boat
batter
no no it sucks
[Applause]
this is no joke this is catering
[Music]
are we having fun yet
no it's actually him cool yeah see you
in 12 years
no this what's party down
an m
[Music]
[Applause]